i'm madison mills welcome back to
bloomberg quick take this week marks a
hundred days since the u.s withdrew its
military presence from afghanistan
following nearly 20 years of conflict in
the nation at the time a lot of
predictions were made following the fall
of kabul but more than three months on
how is the nation doing and where are we
at with those predictions here with the
status update from washington is dr
ariel cohen senior fellow at the
atlantic council dr cohen welcome back
to quick take and thanks for being here
i want to jump right in starting with
the big question on terrorism about
three months ago a lot of the guests we
had on this show talked about the
pending return of al qaeda where do we
stand with that today and what evidence
have you seen if any of a big return to
that level of terror
first of all
i just came back from the region i was
in kazakhstan this is not a border state
but it's still in the heart of eurasia
as is afghanistan and those
folks in kazakhstan keep a close uh and
weary eye on afghanistan
i can tell you that the big challenge
now
is the um clash
between taliban and uh isis uh josh uh
and um
uh sorry and um the threat
uh isis is presenting
to the taliban
so
while the taliban is already
trying to have contacts with
the u.s with qatar with pakistan isis is
in a full jihad mode is fighting um its
taliban uh posts as well as the rest of
the world so these two are duking it out
uh for the control of afghanistan and
many uh among the local
radicals are joining isis uh the second
issue is
that we have a lot of refugees leaving
afghanistan vast majority of them for
good reasons they don't see the future
uh there a lot of people are starving i
was trying desperately to help some
people to leave uh so far
unsuccessful it's very hard
but among these tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of refugees may be
uh radicals who are sent to the west to
uh establish sales uh to conduct attacks
or to conduct attacks in the future so
it's absolutely crucial that the
services in europe and in the united
states screen people who are knocking on
our doors and are saying that they're
refugees
from the pretty horrible regime of
course that taliban had established in
afghanistan and in kabul tell me about
what grade you would give the biden
administration in terms of predicting
how the us withdraw from the region
would impact uh relations between isis
and the taliban for example
uh the overall execution of that
withdrawal is an f
this
is
a collapse of u.s
power structure
in an area that was spent 20 years and
over a trillion dollars trying to
engage in what is called nation building
misleading ourselves telling ourselves
stories uh about what we can accomplish
or not accomplish in afghanistan what we
needed to do there and we failed to do
was go in destroy al qaeda uh destroy
the terrorist infrastructure and then
leave whoever was capable of ruling that
place and uh leave the minimal uh
footprint if we didn't do that if we
stayed there for so long we needed to
continue doing what we're doing in iraq
it's called status of forces agreement
we can leave 2500 3 000
select troops to coordinate airstrikes
to train to equip uh to collect
intelligence now we're blind and deaf
and mute we do not have eyes on the
ground a lot of conversations that i had
when i travel in central asia uh in july
and now is how
crippled we are by
leaving uh afghanistan in its totality
and not keeping an eye uh eyes and ears
on the ground well i wonder to what
extent though that might have been
inevitable i could imagine a biden
administration official saying that
clashes between leaders in the region
and isis were going to happen regardless
of whether or not you the u.s kept
troops on the ground
correct and uh i would point out that
the agreement for us pull out was
undertaken under the trump
administration
but biden continued biden was an
opponent of this broad engagement uh he
was
a supporter of anti-terrorism
approach not
anti-insurgency approach this is
washington speak for broad engagement
versus narrow engagement but once you
were discussing the modalities of that
disengagement or withdrawal you needed
to understand not just the deadline that
biden uh selected the 31st
of uh august you needed to understand
what happened next and we failed in
securing our allies we failed people who
trusted us with their lives we failed
women
who
uh did achieve quite a lot in
the modern post taliban afghanistan for
20 years and now some of them being
hunted and executed and raped and killed
it is horrible what is happening to the
more advanced uh more accomplished
afghan women there were police officers
diplomats um and professors whose lives
are destroyed today or
yeah killed uh in a brutal way in
afghanistan today and i hate to say it
we have something to do with that
spokesman from the taliban were very
quick after the fall of kabul to talk
about how the rights of women and girls
would be different this time around
right that education would be preserved
that freedom would be preserved as well
for women and girls
what have you seen in terms of those
promises did those completely fall flat
was any of it true
uh
from what i understand uh the
mixed classes mixed education is
finished uh i do believe that in the
majority of
careers or professions women were all
kicked out they were told not to come to
work uh
i think with the exception of hospitals
they they need those nurses uh possibly
doctors uh to take care of their sick
and wounded and in universities i
understand that uh women are limited to
women-only classes taught by women or
maybe in saudi like in saudi arabia they
had professors
remotely
teaching
via skype or via
zoom but not being present in the room
of course it limits uh the
um
the
ability of those women to interact they
were with their professors and teachers
and uh it also uh
they also don't allow women to travel
without a male
companion that also happened in saudi
arabia until recently
and in iran
so that is a part of sharia
rules for
women traveling in general people who
are trying to leave afghanistan are
encountering uh two barriers one
internal by the taliban and also
external when people when countries do
not provide them visas so this situation
is critical we need to do more to help
people who want to leave especially our
allies our assets
our
collaborators we need to get them out
the biden administration had also
promised that all individuals who had
assisted u.s troops on the ground would
get out if they wanted to get out and
then later suggested that some
individuals did choose to stay behind
where are we at with that
well
unfortunately there are many more people
who want to get out than people who
chose to stay some of the people who are
trying to get out hold us
um
permanent residence green cards
they cannot get out some of them do not
but they were our
translators
our guides our collaborators so we need
to do much more it's it's a bureaucratic
breakdown a mess
between the state department the defense
department there are a lot of volunteer
groups stepping in because the us
government is not doing a good job
saving the lives of people who risk
their lives
i have
friends who um know people who got
executed it is heartbreaking what
happened there
dr cohen and my final question to you
there's a lot that we've talked about
here and a lot that we didn't even get
to but we are limited in time it's a
hundred days into the fall of kabul what
do you see happening in the next three
months what does the situation on the
ground look like three months from now
when it's been six months total since
the taliban took over
you know there's a lot of chatter about
how taliban needs to become taliban
version 2.0 uh you know the nice and
fluffy taliban it's not going to happen
uh they're not going to abandon uh their
core beliefs their core values which are
the extremist
version of sharia law and start
cooperating with
us there are already hangings and
amputations for
relatively minor um infractions and
crimes um they are brutal and they are
not very important to understand they're
not a united body there are elements
that are terrorists like the haqqani
network that are in key positions in the
taliban government minister of interior
key ministers uh are
parts of the haqqani network which is
recognized as one of the worst terrorist
organizations so we need to work with
others in the region and for this uh
there's no choice by to talk to russia
china pakistan india and others and of
course our friends in central asia who
have better view
better contact with kabul and with the
parts of the taliban regime and we need
to increase our presence there and
around
afghanistan in terms of eyes and ears
and intelligence assets to understand
what the terrorist threats are going to
be
really appreciate you giving that
context for us 100 days in here dr ariel
cohen senior fellow with the atlantic
council thanks for joining us again here
on quick take that's going to do it for
us right now but stick with us for more
quick take ahead right here